well this is a reflection about seeing
the Earth from space it's a kind of
meditation on what transpires within our
very Consciousness as we gaze upon the
pale blue dot these words are by Dom
delillo and I find them so
poignant
here goes
the view is endlessly fulfilling it is
like the answer to a lifetime of
questions and vague Cravings it
satisfies every childlike curiosity
every muted desire whatever there is in
him of the scientist the poet
primitive Seer The Watcher of fire and
shooting stars whatever obsessions eat
at the night side of his mind whatever
sweet and dreamy yearning he has ever
felt for nameless places far away
whatever Earth Sense he possesses the
neural pulse of some Wilder awareness
sympathy for beasts whatever belief in
an imminent vital force the Lord of
creation whatever secret harboring of
the idea of human Oneness whatever
wishfulness and simple-hearted hope
whatever of too much and not enough all
at once and little by little whatever
burning urge to escape responsibility
and routine Escape his own over
specialization the circumscribed and
inward spiraling self whatever remnants
of his boyish Longing To Fly his dreams
of strange spaces and Eerie Heights
fantasies of happy death whatever
indolent and sybaritic leanings Lotus
eater smoker of grasses and herbs
blue-eyed gazer into space
all of these are satisfied all collected
and masked in that living body the sight
he sees
in that window
now I don't know about you but I feel
transported by these words and they
really do seem like the answer to the
existential question to the weight of
being to the question of what to do with
ourselves
the answer it seems simply to Marvel
[Music]